alright here we are and these are the
questions people have sent in Lesley
what inspired you to write your new book
becoming grandma let me take a wild
guess you became a grandma
these are audience whoa it can't keep up
with it
I will tell you how it happened cuz they
the publisher first asked me to write us
an inside story of 60 minutes and I knew
that if I did that no I told the truth
out on my ear yeah so then this was the
second idea went but the second idea but
really what's going on with Steve Crowe
he was getting some wasn't I'm not gonna
tell you okay I'm gonna talk to you
about being a grandmother okay the book
can I talk about the book for one second
of course all right it's not just about
being a grandmother
it's about misleading it's not just
about the pleasure of being a
grandmother it's about the science the
biochemistry it's about the history it's
about attention mm-hmm it's about the
tension with your daughter-in-law what
the history of grandmother Darrell do
you have a child
grandmother ism was invented in the late
17th century before they're not exist
there's the grandmothers human
grandmothers are one of the few normies
right humans are one of the few animals
on the planet that have grandmother's to
nurture and take care of babies animals
die when they are no longer able to
reproduce generally speaking right so
humans that we live in living long
enough to take care of our children's
children is the very reason that humans
even exist it's called the grandmother
theory and I was a child I even had a
great-grandmother
oh yeah that's unusual for really right
but today it's not a child though
Georgia yeah I was a jock not my great
grandmother she was old but people got
married younger and younger so that
right there were a lot but grandmothers
going back to the caveman times took
care of the babies and we've gotten away
from that and I met my grandmother at 40
I remember in the movie The Verge wisdom
the 40 year old virgin what two year old
virgin it was like a hot grandmother and
they have a child at 16 and the next
child has a child sure right children
having children as Newt Gingrich used to
say Van Jones do you see hope for
bipartisanship and the efforts to reform
our criminal justice system you know
actually I do and you know you just [ __ ]
that what's your grandmother lives
he provides a lot of care and nurturing
for the grand cherry in the morning in
the black community exactly I think so
grant Graham with a great grand however
right a diagram however technically they
are called Big Momma's we don't call we
don't have zits all right that's right
that's right it's not just in the middle
it's not just in the movies but I had a
Big Mama
I had a Big Daddy they were they were
also played by Martin Lawrence re um
nobody I do
you mentioned Newt Gingrich Newton I
actually had a TV show together called
crossfire for another half an hour and
then afterwards it turned down to reboot
of course reboot right but actually
turned out the only thing we agreed on
was the idea that the criminal justice
system has become from the point of view
of conservatives a big failed government
bureaucracy they grows and grows and
gobbles up more money the worst job it
gets and so we can actually work
together on one thing cutting that stuff
out that's the only thing you agreed on
and on everything else we just
handicapped on the moon yeah we listen
whatever it would it no you don't hm
what Newt wants the handicapped on the
moon I might anybody know what I'm
talking about I'm not making yeah we
build a nice little moon base forum a
bunch of pillows to love it
going back into your coffee yeah yeah
it's a mafia character appearance no he
says because there's no gravity and so
it wouldn't rip its I'm a dude Gingrich
a lot though you think I graduate I
haven't haven't read all these ideas
that got granted okay Obama is in
Britain today your home country does the
UK US special relationship still exists
yes I would it always will how could it
not then the mother country yeah as a
little what about the grandmother
country it's very popular it's very
popular I was reading this morning Obama
yeah he should be 79 percent or
something but but he has annoyed some
people and I think quite quite fairly
they're annoyed by wading into the
debate over the European Union firstly I
met you didn't I why did he went a bit
further than commenting I think and
firstly it's odd given American
independence to get too involved in
whether a country should stay with a
larger political union it does affect us
though no it does it does I'm some but I
also think that he he sort of threatened
the country today he said well we won't
be too interested in a trade deal with
you guys if if you leave the EU and come
on I mean it Britain in America the
trade between the two countries is
extraordinary at any given points so I
don't think it worked and what is what
is your feeling about the European Union
stay in I know I would leave I would
leave if for me it's a matter of
sovereignty more than anything else but
don't they have the best of both worlds
because there none on the currency I
mean they are quasi independent from it
well it to me supposed to most countries
who have to throw their whole lot in to
me to me it's just a question of basic
sovereignty if you elect people they
shouldn't give away the power you've
loaned them and that's what's happened
with Europe you know the Parliament was
elected by the people and then the
Parliament gave it to people who aren't
elected and they can make laws within
England I don't think America would
accept that with another country I don't
know the West rebate is gonna be settled
by Isis by the way well I think no I
mean actually done a couple more attacks
in the Nakano maybe I didn't think
Britain will leave I think they'll stay
do you think Obama's become a completely
different person he was so careful for
eight seven eight years and all of a
sudden he's saying things about Saudi
Arabia senioritis yeah is it see me
writing so I could
last six months senioritis yeah what's
he got to lose
he is so outspoken we call it swagger
yeah that's right okay uh how should the
government combat the epidemic of
prescription drug abuse
well that's relevant because we heard
the sad news about our friend Prince
that apparently he was yeah we all love
Prince but that's the news today that
apparently he you know probably and by
the way this is this is a common story
in show business I could think a lot of
people Jerry Lewis Chevy Chase comedians
who did pratfalls hurt themselves
musician to hurt themselves and that's
when you have to start taking they give
you oxycontin they give you oxy codeine
these these basic it's basically heroin
I mean poor people wind up doing heroin
because they can't afford the
prescription drugs anymore but
apparently well that is not it's not
been confirmed and obviously I'm
somebody quite close to him and quite
close to the family and I'm wearing my
rest in purple so but so kind of taking
him out of it has not been confirmed
what I will say is that I'm glad that
we're finally able to have a
conversation when I watched the
Republican Party hugging heroin addicted
folks opioid addicted folks it makes me
very happy but it also makes me very mad
because those same Republicans and
Democrats when the problem was crack
showed no mercy no compassion no
understanding at all and locked up a
whole bunch of people so I do I do think
that now that it's hitting everybody
hopefully with a more compassionate
response okay Thomas Middleditch do you
find that to make it in comedy these
days you must be active on social media
I think if you look at my Twitter feed
you'll find that I don't
oh my god I'm like a 1:1 tweet about
like what my poo looks like a week in
this uh interesting get a squatty potty
piece I don't so they know you don't do
a lot of tweeting I don't know well I'm
in here and there but yeah I should be
better at it too but I but when I do
what I enjoy it it's I thought it at the
beginning but it is what it's like it's
like epigrams you know like in the old
days you know the old Victorian writers
or then I'm old writers Francis Bacon
now ever that ever was there was a there
was a art to being very concise you know
a still no names time those kind of or
being a [ __ ] like that orange guy
running for president and part of the
problem that we have
color understand but-but-but part of the
problem we have is that the reason I
think that Trump has been so successful
is because this is a new media moment
you know FDR so true right FDR under
radio he died JFK understood television
dominate so true Obama measured the
Internet dominated this guy understands
social media and reality television he's
dominating and everybody else is playing
by the old rules yeah right so that's
you know and and I thought and I think
we thought he was going to leave the
entertainment world and come over the
wall into politics he's pulled politics
over into the world of entertainment
we're now living in his reality TV show
and I don't like it I don't like at all
that's good Lawrence Wright your play
Camp David is about the 1978
negotiations between Egypt and Israel
I remember that you remember that your
kids don't yeah you see any reason do
you see any reason to hope for further
progress for peace Wow
that's a tough one but as a source
always I mean if you look at Camp David
Carter big and Sadat you had a failing
president and Marcy Carter was failing
yeah I mean you know Jeb stagflation and
isolation all the gas lines farmers when
the tractors in the UH exactly right so
he wasn't he was he he started out with
very high poll numbers and they was ski
slope down and then Anwar Sadat we think
of him as being such a noble he was an
assassin he'd been in prison twice he
managed to kill one of the government
ministers he was a Nazi sympathizer
Menachem Bagan was a terrorist prep one
of the great lowest English but yeah
mostly had an assassin a terrorist in a
failing president and they made peace so
don't tell me that you need the right
people you just need people with
political courage now Jimmy Carter gets
[ __ ] on so much what a ballsy guy I'm
the only president who didn't fire a
shot ever in office yeah and he got the
hostages home and they all live they all
survived what sounds like a [ __ ] the
Iranian huh
Jimmy Carter yeah well I did landed the
second reagan-begin well they waited
because deliberately but they didn't
keep by just being calm and not waking
in it exclude tried he tried to fire a
shot he just missed but anyway I mean
right I love Timmy course Simon right
the helicopter crash yes it did you know
when when Obama went to get bin Laden he
said huh
let's send an extra helicopter yeah yeah
that was a good idea pretty badass
alright thank you everybody